construct a square inscribed inside the
circle in order to do this we just have
to remember that a square well we know
of squares all four sides are congruent
and they intersect at right angles and
we also have to remember that the two
diagonals of the square are going to be
perpendicular bisectors of each other so
let's see if we can construct two lines
that are perpendicular bisectors of each
other and essentially where those two
lines intersect our bigger circle those
are going to be the vertices of our
square so let's throw a straightedge
right over here and let's make a
diameter so that's a diameter right over
here just goes through the circle goes
through the center of the circle and two
two sides of the circle and now let's
think about how it can construct a
perpendicular bisector of this and we've
done this in other compass construction
or construction videos but what we can
do is we can put a circle let's throw a
circle right over here we got a we got
to make its radius bigger than the
center what we're going to do is going
to reuse this we're going to make
another circle it's the exact same size
put it there and where they intersect is
going to be exactly along those two
points of intersection are going to be
along a perpendicular bisector so that's
one of them let's do another one
I want a circle of the exact same
dimensions so I'll Center it at the same
place I'll drag it out there that looks
pretty good I'll move it on to this side
the other side of my diameter so that
looks pretty good and notice I connect
that point to that point I have now I
will have constructed a perpendicular
bisector of this original segment so
let's do that
let's connect those two points so that
point and that point we could just keep
going all the way to so keep going all
the way to the end of the circle go all
the way over all the way over there that
looks pretty good and now we just have
to connect these four points to have a
square so let's do that so I'll connect
to that and that
and then I will connect throw another
straightedge there I will connect that
with that and then two more to go
I'll connect this with that and then one
more I can connect this with that and
there you go
I have a shape whose vertices intersect
the circle and its diagonals this
diagonal and this diagonal these are
perpendicular bisectors